welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode
numero 2. i'm stoked i find podcasting
is a great way to get some of my
overflowing extroversion
out i hope you're doing well and the
quarantine isn't getting you down too
badly
apparently one-third of people who are
in quarantine are depressed
that's a horrible statistic dad
throughout the other day hopefully it's
not true
today i'm going to be speaking with my
good friend max lugovir
max sent me his book genius foods in
2018.
the book would have been more useful in
2015 given the fact i was already on my
all beef lion died in 2018 and feeling
great
but i read it anyway it's a great
resource for someone looking to optimize
their health and
isn't willing to give my diet a shot or
doesn't need to
when i went to one of my dad's first
shows at the beacon theater in new york
i invited max to come join just to say
hi he's a best-selling author
in the food realm like me but unlike a
lot of food nerds he's not a dweeb and i
wanted to meet him i mean no offense to
food nerds by the way
i say dweeb with love we've been friends
since then
i really admire his ability to convince
people who aren't interested in diet
that diet is important to health and i
enjoy the fact he makes cutting things
out of your diet actually appear cool
that's what i try to do but try selling
an all beef diet
it ain't easy folks he appeals to the
general public and is fringe in a much
less dramatic and possibly more
effective way than i am fringe
so without further ado
[Applause]
[Music]
hi max welcome to my podcast it's so
good to be here i'm so proud of you and
excited for you this is awesome
thank you thank you you're only the
second person i'm interviewing i chose
you to be
well you could have been first but
somebody else responded first
oh man well i'm honored nonetheless
being two is better than being like 200
exactly exactly um okay i thought we
should start off a bit
by giving my audience which is probably
mainly
like carnivore folks i don't know
carnivore folks maybe
some of my dad's fans um a bit of a
background on
who you are the books you've written
why you wrote those books i thought you
should start with that a bit
yeah for sure well my name is max i
guess i started as a journalist
um working for a tv network that was
co-founded by al gore called current tv
which i did in the early i don't know
how
how you describe the early 2000s yeah
the early 2000s so
from 2005 to 2011 uh i did that
and um i was a bit of a generalist there
um and it was my first job out of
college i
i've never been into politics so for
anybody who's gonna paint me as like you
know having been a part of like the al
gore
agenda i really just it was my first job
out of school and i was so psyched to be
able to be
on camera and to be able to produce
content that was like
informational and educational but also
entertaining and inspiring to a young
adult audience and i did that
i learned how to really hone my chops as
a storyteller
and as a filmmaker and as a journalist
when i left
that job in about 2011 my mom got sick
and i know you can relate to this um
michaela but
when a loved one gets sick your world
just stops
and i had always had a lifelong passion
for health and nutrition
for as long as i can remember i have
been interested
in nutrition science and in fact when i
started college i was actually on the
pre-medical track and i ended up
realizing a lot of creativity and
artistry and i kind of
pivoted but i've always been very very
much into
health and science and nutrition and
i've always kind of like walked the walk
and i've also
always kind of seen my like my peers
kind of like gravitate to me and my
thinking
about fitness and nutrition and things
like that even though i've
you know never had any sort of formal
training in the area
i think i've always had like a pretty
good instinct or aptitude for um
for these kinds of things so when my mom
got sick in about 2011
i basically i was professionally i was
in between jobs and i decided to
step in to go with my mom to doctor's
visits to try to understand what was
going on
she started to complain of brain fog and
she also had a
change to her her gait and i had no
prior family history of any type of
dementia so i had no framework for
understanding any of her complaints but
as a layperson and as somebody who loved
you know his mother very very deeply i
wanted to
be her patient wingman and i started
going with her to doctors appointment
after doctor's appointment
and it was really hard to get a
diagnosis ultimately what we had to do
was we ended up having to go to the
cleveland clinic
in ohio which is known for taking on
very complex medical cases and this was
so long ago that i didn't even know what
functional medicine was which is
you know sort of a term thrown about in
health and nutrition these days but the
cleveland clinic is known for kind of
taking an all hands-on
approach you know that's at least kind
of my perception of it at the time and
so we had to we had to fly out there
from new york city which is where we're
from
and it was there for the first time that
my mom was diagnosed with a
neurodegenerative condition and she was
prescribed drugs for both alzheimer's
disease and parkinson's disease
and that was the first time in my life
i'd ever i'd ever had a panic attack
just you know yeah ruminating
on the possibility that my mom could
have this incurable
and ultimately fatal condition that was
going to rob her of
the essence of who she was and at that
point basically it was like
to borrow a term from astrophysics it
was like a singularity in my life like
there was before
and and suddenly everything going
forward
became about trying to understand what
was going on with my mom
how i might be able to potentially help
her from the standpoint of diet and
lifestyle which are the tools that we
all have access to
and what could be done to prevent myself
from ever
having to succumb to you know the kind
of accelerated aging that i was seeing
in my mom
and that began a journey that's going to
continue for the rest of my life
and it led to me really doing a deep
dive into looking at the risk factors
and the interventions that
you know basically any any any aspect of
nutrition science and fitness science
and and
what have you that pertains to brain
health and better cognition
and dementia risk mitigation and that
became the basis of my work and so
genius foods
is my first book it's a new york times
bestseller
very grateful to to have that title it's
now published in
eight or nine languages around the world
it really is a nutritional care manual
to the human brain
and my second book just came out it's
called the genius life and it's more of
a lifestyle guide
and so i think what i bring to the table
you know i mean you do such amazing work
there's a lot of there's you know there
are obviously
other people in the space but i think
that i'm really interested in in
longevity health span with a focus on
brain health and cognitive health and i
mean i guess more loosely cognitive
performance
um mental health and uh and under that
sort of purview i'm
you know i've sort of got my fingers in
all sort of different areas like nutri
i'm a huge nutrition nerd and
i talk about these topics on my podcast
regularly which is also called the
genius life but
essentially what i've realized i guess
there are two important
things to realize one is that dementia
often begins in the brain decades before
the first symptom that's what the best
available
evidence is telling us that dementia is
not an old person's condition
it's not really a genetic condition
either we have genetic risk factors but
ultimately if you have a brain you are
at risk
for developing dementia and there are
various
sort of comorbidities that can that can
increase that risk or decrease that risk
and then the second thing is that the
modern world has become like the hunger
games
like our brains are being attacked from
every which way and to really
um protect yourself i mean you've got to
do your due diligence and you've got
to kind of be aware of all these factors
that
that it takes to be healthy today
whether it's nutrition or whether it's
our exposure to
everyday you know toxins in the
environment or
uh you know just the lack of of exercise
that we're all getting
these days so um it's pretty
multi-faceted and multi-factorial but
but yeah that's kind of like the basis
of my of my work
um how old was your mom when she started
experiencing symptoms
she was young she was like 58 57 58
and uh spirited new yorker you know like
had had all the vitality of a younger
person i mean i don't think you know
especially today when you're in your 50s
you're not an old person
and again i didn't have any prior family
history of any any type of dementia or
anything like that so i was just
blindsided
like me and my family were so ignorant
to what my mom was displaying
and yeah unfortunately she passed away
about a year and a half ago
and she passed not from dementia but she
um she developed in mid-2018
uh pancreatic cancer and so
yeah it was awful it was awful so so i
feel
very motivated um to help people
and you know i'm very i never
misrepresent myself
like i didn't go to medical school but i
think that understanding all of
these factors is something that like you
know nobody's really getting good
information these days nobody knows
where to look for for good information
and ultimately i don't think that
healthcare is something that can be
offered by
a healthcare system i think what we have
is a sick care system i know you know
this better than anybody
so i've sort of decided to stand up
and and use my abilities and my access
to uh to help people understand what it
means to live healthier what i call a
genius life today
because you know people like my mom
people just in general citizens
are are underserved you know i don't
think media does a good job
of conveying health science medical
doctors are not experts when it comes to
nutrition and i think it's a lot to ask
for medical doctors to
offer nutrition plans to people i think
this is really something that you've got
to take ownership
over those are definitely different
things and one of the frustrating
experiences i've had with doctors and
what i've come to realize is
most people who go to medical school
aren't researchers like
there's a difference between there are
doctors that are researchers but
doctors aren't researchers so and if
you're motivated especially by having
something like a sick family member
there is a lot and you're smart there's
a lot of research you can do
that's available to figure out what's
going on especially in the nutrition
realm especially now like 2011
there's a lot less going on in the
nutrition realm than there is now
but yeah i'm sorry you went through that
like i know what it's like going
to doctor's appointments repeatedly
with somebody dying and it is not fun
yeah i've
i've coined a term for it i've you know
what i experienced with my mom
i've come to call diagnose and adios
that's pretty much
oh god yeah that's pretty much
it's cold you know and it's it's it's
sad but it's the truth
it's the truth i mean one with my mom's
cancer and with her dementia
mainstream medicine wasn't really able
to offer her anything and neither was
alternative medicine
so i've i've really become just
passionate about the notion of
prevention and being very sort of
evidence-based in my approach but not
evidence-bound
you know i think it's i think data is
important but
i think there are but i think data data
can only get you half of the way there
at the end of the day you have to sort
of have like a philosophy about your
approach to diet and lifestyle and
because science is in fact science is
not infallible it's a method of asking
questions and seeking answers but
science doesn't know
everything science certainly wasn't able
to provide solutions for my mother
we don't know how a particular diet is
going to affect you
you know all we have are probabilities
so i think i think
my message is is really one of
empowerment and i know it's yours too
i think that's why you know we there's
such synergy in what we do
yeah i agree figure it out yourself pay
attention to your body
don't necessarily listen to what anybody
else says
yeah exactly exactly i think that's a
big part of it okay
so for people who aren't aware of what's
in your book like what are the
key foods like according to you that
people should not be eating
like you resonate really well with
people who
kind of want an overall healthy diet and
want something that makes sense and i
feel like your diet
makes sense if you think about it
whereas i'm you know talking about a
diet that doesn't make
sense to most people so i thought you
could delve into
like a little bit into what major foods
to avoid
and why yeah uh well i just want to
start out by saying i'm definitely
carnivore diet like adjacent like i'm a
friend of the carnivores
because i'm not no yeah i'm a big
advocate of meat consumption like i
think that red
red meat properly raised red meat is a
is a freaking
health food and there's really no ifs
ands or buts about it and in fact
you know i would never claim that meat
abstention uh was the cause of my
mother's illness but my mom
was largely vegetarian she rarely ate
meat and when she did it was just like
lean chicken breast for the protein she
never ate eggs i never saw her ever
eating eggs because she was afraid of
heart disease so she never ate you know
dietary cholesterol she never
she was a big animal rights advocate too
um and so she never ate
any type of ruminant animal never cow
you know never beef or anything like
that
and i really think that there's just you
know there's no debating at this point
the fact that red meat is crucially
i mean nutrient dense and it's amazing
so i think like the difference is that i
you know i think that plants you know
can be
also beneficial and it depends on the
person um
but you know i eat a largely omnivorous
diet the foods that i think
um people should avoid i think the grain
and seed oils
is pretty it's it's pretty cut and dry
at this point that um
you know these industrially processed
oils grape seed oil
soybean oil corn oil canola oil
they're pretty bad from the standpoint
of cardiovascular health of brain health
they're you know they're chemically
damaged uh
fats and you know in particular when it
comes to the brain when you're consuming
the fat the type of fat that you consume
uh weighs heavily on the chemical
composition of the brain on the fat you
know the fat
the fatty acid composition of the brain
because the brain is by and large made
of fat
i'm not a big advocate of consuming
excessive amounts of saturated fat i've
just spent
too much time with exposure to you know
people who are
you know with in regard to risk for
dementia there's a condition that
or not a condition there's a gene allele
that a quarter of the population carry
it's the apoe4 allele
and we're just at the very tip of the
iceberg of nutrigenomics understanding
how different diets affect different
people with different genes but
you know the the the best thinking that
we have is that a high saturated fat
diet
for that population is probably not
going to be ideal
uh so while i think certain people can
do really well with lots and lots of
saturated fat
there is no one size fits dietary
approach and so
the the fat that i think is probably
going to be the most beneficial for the
most people is a monounsaturated fat and
so that's why i
advocate for you know extra virgin olive
oil
which also has a number of
phytochemicals in it that have been
shown to be
you know beneficial in a number of
different types of studies
and maybe avocado oil is a close second
but um
but yeah i'm a huge fan of of of
meat as i mentioned um avoiding
industrially refined grain and seed oils
um and then i think for most people
uh you know catering carbohydrate
consumption
to activity levels so i'm not like
always in in ketosis or anything like
that but i do
advocate for uh you know intermittent
ketosis so whether that's like on a
daily basis on a weekly basis or even a
seasonal basis i think
if you're consuming car dietary
carbohydrates
and i'm sort of excluding fiber from
this when i say dietary carbohydrates i
mean specifically like glucose
producing carbs you want to consume them
in a way that is commensurate with your
activity levels and your fitness levels
so most people are desk jockeys you know
with
and get minimal physical activity and
probably have some degree of glucose
intolerance you know insulin resistance
the latest research suggests that only
12 percent of people in the united
states are in
quote unquote good metabolic health when
looking at biomarkers like
ldl hdl triglycerides things like that
and so for most people i would say a low
carbohydrate diet
probably very beneficial that would be
like my my baseline
diet and then if you're working out
regularly you know and if you're
especially if you're an athlete or
you're a fitness competitor
i think that you can titrate your
carbohydrate intake up in accordance
with your needs and to use carbohydrates
as a performance enhancing tool
and certainly i do this you know like to
be very
topical you know i think a lot of people
spending a lot more time in my house
these days so i'm a lot i've got a lot
less non-exercise
activity thermogenesis going on i'm like
not i don't have access to the gym and
i'm still working out but i would say
that my overall activity levels have
declined a lot
so i'm actually like eating a lot fewer
carbohydrates than i normally would
normally if i'm able to go to the gym
and you know
crush an amazing high intensity uh
workout and do lots of like glycolytic
exercise
afterwards i'm okay having like a few
sweet potato wedges and
you know maybe having a little bit more
fruit here and there but these days i'm
i'm
a lot less active so i'm eating fewer
carbs okay
it does fewer does that look like like
meat and salad like what does your day
of food usually look like
yeah pretty much you know the other day
i broke my
fast you know i'm a sort of fan of
intermittent fasting
for a number of different reasons which
we could talk about but um the other day
i broke my fast with a bowl
of uh i had like i don't know six to
eight ounces of grass-fed
steak with two pastured eggs over it
i mean so good uh over a bowl of like
cauliflower rice with maybe like some
like
cucumbers and and tomatoes and i felt
great you know like that was like the
perfect
you know amount of you know i mean very
little starch
for me but it was like highly satiating
and i felt you know my hunger levels
were super stable i felt very energetic
throughout the day after eating that
and yeah usually it's like greens and
meat and i'll sort of eat both
yeah part of it for me is you know like
i also i enjoy
i think what i've heard from the
carnivore community is that many people
in the carnivore community just don't
like vegetables don't like produce
you know what i actually don't believe
that at all
really i don't i don't believe that at
all no i mean
a lot of people say that but a lot of
people who are stuck on this diet also
convince themselves that
because they feel so much better on this
diet they look back at it and think wow
i didn't really like those foods anyway
but it's kind of a coping mechanism
nobody
i that's what i think and people can
complain about that and
tell me i'm wrong if they want to but
for me like i really liked salad
i had i was on a like a meat and greens
diet for a couple of years before before
i went to the carnivore diet and the
only reason i stopped was because
for some reason my tolerance to
vegetables disappeared but
no i don't believe that that certainly
isn't the case for dad either like both
of us
actually enjoy other foods
yeah i had uh sean baker on my podcast
and he was
you know he he kind of echoed that you
know like he just doesn't like
for any type of produce as much as he
likes meat and i love meat
so i mean you know i'm a huge yeah i
would
i would choose meat over other foods
obviously if i had to choose but
um i was a salad fan for sure yeah and a
cauliflower fan and just all foods
i liked everything except for eggplant
yeah and sun-dried tomatoes
you know like sun-dried tomatoes i don't
like it i hated sun-dried
yeah interesting interesting and i'm
always flexible so i'm not dogmatic
about this so for your you know your
carnivore listeners who are like what
you know why is max uh you know talking
about the virtues of salad
well you know i mean when it comes to
the brain like
we know more about space than we know
about our own brains right but the data
that we do have
you know i think it's important to um
kind of honor
like you know the breadcrumbs that we do
have on the on the trail to truth
and so i generally will will advocate
for a bowl of dark leafy greens uh every
day
research out of rush university has
shown us that people who who eat
you know about a cup and a third of dark
leafy greens every day have brains that
actually perform about 11 years younger
on scans now this is totally correlation
it's not causation and there's probably
a strong healthy user bias in somebody
who's eating a big salad every single
day right
but we know that dark leafy greens
contain compounds called carotenoids
which
they've actually shown in a randomized
controlled trial of
young healthy college students that
increased consumption of these
compounds like lutein and zeaxanthin can
actually confer
a visual processing speed boost by about
20 percent which is kind of remarkable
because young people are already that
whole
yeah sorry that whole um carrots make
you see better thing there's actually
something to that i mean what beta
carotene
yeah i mean well we've known for a long
time that
carotenoids can benefit eye health like
beta carotene lutein zeaxanthin can all
help
ward off age-related macular
degeneration so if you look at like
eye supplements that you'll find even at
your local drug store they're all going
to
contain like beta-carotene and lutein
zeaxanth and interestingly
and another reason why you know meat is
so valuable
many people a significant portion of the
population can't uh properly or
efficiently convert beta-carotene to
retinol which is
the active form of vitamin a in the body
but
zeaxanthin are actually they're not
necessarily essential
but we now know that these compounds can
also accumulate in the brain and there
have been a number of observational
studies that show that people who have
higher levels of these two carotenoids
in their brains they have better
cognitive aging they have better
performing brains and we now know with
actually controlled trials that just
supplementing with these two compounds i
believe it's about
12 milligrams a day of combined lutein
and zeaxanthin
can actually boost brain processing
speed and
your average adult consumes about two
milligrams of combined
lutein and zeaxanthin every day so that
i think is one of the mechanisms by
which you know eating a salad every day
might uh help the brain a bowl of kale
has like 12 to 24 milligrams of these
two combined
compounds and i know some people you
know will will
groan about oxalates and things like
that but but i think for like you know
for most people you can get by with
these kinds of greens without much
risk to your health and in fact probably
a little bit you know more
more on the benefit side of the of the
seesaw as opposed to
you know more risk i think every every
treatment you've got to weigh risk
versus benefits everything else
yeah for sure you know there's a risk
benefit analysis that you've got to
literally do for
everything right like going to the gym
and performing high-intensity exercise
has a risk to it sitting in a sauna has
a risk to it everything has writ so i'm
not trying to eliminate all risk from my
from my life that would be cr a i would
seem like a crazy person
but i think i think i think when you
choose to adopt these various
interventions or diets or foods or
activities you do so because you assume
that the benefits are going to outweigh
the risks
so for me i feel like the benefits of
eating
you know dark leafy greens are going to
outweigh any potential risk and look
i don't i haven't i feel like why i feel
like you've been on
a lot of podcasts being attacked for
your vegetables
i just have that happened it hasn't i
mean
i've had enough conversations with paul
saladino and i've
spoken recently with uh with sean baker
and you
and i just think it's uh
you know i like to promote this you know
i like to
look p like if you were a registered
dietitian you would say that i have a
very extreme diet because i don't eat
freaking grains and grain products and
packaged foods right you would say that
my diet's extreme
so i just like to bring a little bit of
like
balance but not like balance in the like
usda
like food pyramid sense oh yes to the
world like you can have a little bit of
coca-cola per day yeah i'm not like
advocating
that but yeah i mean i like to kind of
um take what the carnivores say
and kind of add my own logic and
reasoning
to it you know yeah well i think it
would
appeal to the masses much more than the
carnivore diet does unless you're
you know extremely disagreeable
yeah a lot of people just jump on the
train for that uh i don't actually have
anything against vegetables unlike um
some of the other carnivores like my my
idea of the carnivore diet is there are
a lot of people with
really really really severe gut damage
so i'm like
as you know i'm mostly focused on people
with autoimmune disorders yes
and i think a lot of i've seen a lot of
people get benefit from eliminating
gut irritating foods assuming you
already have that damage
so like eating a bunch of kale for
somebody with crohn's
who probably has a lot of gut damage can
be more irritating than beneficial
but the idea and i'm hoping for me i'm
hoping
what will happen eventually is i'll do
this diet heal whatever the problem is
there might be some
i think there's some sort of microbiome
issue going on um i already had
um i had like a really bad c difficile
infection
um last year which is gone thank god but
my idea is to
like get back to kind of what i was
doing before which is very
it's more restrictive but very similar
to the diet you talk about
in genius foods which is you know grain
free
i was really strictly legume free as
well processed food free
and was eating mostly like greens low
carb
but i think that makes sense for healthy
people
and if you can do that like good but if
you're suffering more
there's always the meat diet and then
you can work other things back in
i'm also not huge on the whole oxalate
train thing either
because i think that there's a lot of
speculation that goes into that
yeah i'm not i mean i'm also not one of
these guys who is
who's gonna like uh you know
like undermine the benefits that
people with autoimmune conditions um
claim that they've experienced
from going like on a
vegetable-free diet and adopting a
carnivore diet like i
think that there's good reasoning behind
the carnivore diet and i and i don't
believe that there is such thing as a
one-size-fits-all diet so i think
we have to remain open-minded i'm not
one of these guys who's going to use
like
data as a crucifix you know like i think
they're
like i can't stand those people either
so
so yeah i'm i'm totally in support and i
come at this from a place of like i've
never had any digestive problems
you know and i i've been pretty lucky
with my own health i've been very
my family has been very unlucky with
health and i you know
the the it's been a major tragedy in my
life what my mom
went through and so that really is my
focus but my mom
you know my mom's never had any that i
know of but i've been in
enough doctors you know offices with my
mom my mom never really had any major
digestive issues
um i don't that i know of nobody in my
family
really has any any type of autoimmune
nobody nobody in my family has an
autoimmune condition my mom did
one of the earliest things to go awry
with her health was she started
she she had thyroid dysfunction
ultimately leading to uh a physician
destroying her thyroid she was she had
hyperthyroidism
and she was at risk for graves disease
you know and so
i don't you know i think that when it
comes to thyroid health and autoimmunity
i think gluten is one of these things
that
is is you know i think there's probably
a solid body of evidence there and so i
advocate for absention from gluten
containing products
and i think that you know again i have
another hypothesis that they that may
have helped that maybe would have helped
my mom my mom was on a on a high gluten
diet you know if you want to conceive of
that my mom
grew up eating bagels and wheat products
and things like that which she always
thought were going to be good for her
because they had no
wheat products generally are low in fat
and low in cholesterol and
etc etc so um so yeah i'm
i'm pro the avoidance of gluten uh
but you know which is a which is a
lectin but
other than that i think um you know if
you want to enjoy
if you're active and you want to enjoy a
honeycrisp apple or an orange you know
i'm not
i'm not opposed to that you know for
most people yeah
okay that makes sense um what do you
think of gun trees
you know it's dr stephen gundry's
lectin-free diet
well i think you know anything about
that it probably has merit for people
with autoimmune conditions you know at
the very least a good elimination diet
to see what's aggravating your symptoms
um you know a lot of these plant
proteins
i mean i do think that that's why i say
that i think that there's um
there's good reasoning underlying why
you know removing a lot of these plants
from your diet could improve symptoms
because many of the molecules found in
these kinds of plants incite what's
called molecular mimicry
in the body gluten is a perfect example
of that where you know if you have a
dysfunctional immune system
and let's just say for the purpose of
this conversation you know to
define a dysfunctional immune system
would be somebody with
active autoimmunity or you know or an
inflammatory condition
your immune system is basically confused
and overactive and so by removing these
products from your diet
you're probably giving your immune
system a break you know whereas
the you know consumption and even the
over consumption of these kinds of foods
is going to take an already confused
immune system and just let it
run amok like an angry hulk you know and
then you consider the fact that
gluten is not just
you know a protein that no human can
properly digest
but it's something that the mod the
standard american diet has just become
saturated in
you know at every single meal in the
context of widespread gut dysbiosis and
antibiotic overuse
and you know and things like that i
think it's
you know it stands to reason that that's
why so many of us are just are suffering
and rates of autoimmunity
seem to be increasing not declining you
know like medicine we seem to be
like you know our insight into the
workings of the human body
increases obviously every year right um
but still that doesn't seem to help the
fact that it doesn't seem to
play a role in the fact that um
incidence of autoimmunity
increases every year you know people are
getting fatter and sicker
younger too and younger yeah so sicker
at a younger age yeah
yeah exactly so okay i think we're kind
of on the same page in regards to gluten
the first like the first thing that i
figured out when i was trying to figure
out how
to stop myself from dying was oh there's
actually a huge body of
research and a lot of evidence that
gluten is not good for people
there are there's there were so many
papers and i guess they didn't they
weren't
they weren't really out until about 2015
but linking gluten to
schizophrenia or other mental disorders
so yeah
gluten i don't like gluten i think that
caused a lot of my problems
yeah there's a huge overlap with celiac
disease which
is obviously it's an autoimmune
condition that if you consume gluten and
you have celiac disease there's a
violent
you know immune response in the gut but
celiac disease
tends to overlap other autoimmune
conditions more than those other
autoimmune conditions overlap with one
another
so it seems to be this sort of mediator
uh
you know the gut seems to be this this
mediator linking you know
all sorts of autoimmune conditions that
wouldn't otherwise seem to be related to
one another
and especially with thyroid you know the
thyroid where you see a huge
concentration of these transglutaminase
enzymes which look a lot like
you know the proteins um
you know the gluten protein so when
you're having an
auto when you're having an immune
response to the protein
you know one of the proteins in gluten
your body will also then attack these
enzymes which are highly concentrated in
the thyroid so that's why i think
there's some there's a huge overlap
um and people with autoimmune thyroid
conditions seem to do
a lot better when they remove gluten
from their diets
and as i mentioned my mom was somebody
who started to have thyroid dysfunction
really early on
i think that if she were to have removed
gluten from her diet that it would have
helped
i'll never be able to you know test that
hypothesis but i've you know i've chosen
to adopt
a gluten-free diet and then but i'm also
even that i'm not uh dogmatic about it i
think there's probably a dose
effect and if you are healthy and you've
got a you know good robust immune system
and a healthy microbiome and you're
gonna you know your digestion is is on
point and you don't have autoimmunity
um and you don't have an inflammatory
condition there's probably a dose makes
the poison effect with gluten too i mean
you know you might be able to have a
piece of sourdough bread once in a while
so
that's an area where i've actually kind
of like softened my
um my approach i don't eat bread but uh
but you know for but i think that it's
probably there's probably a dose thing
on the other hand in the standard
american diet gluten is just freaking
everywhere it's in our sauces and our
gravies and
you know sandwich culture right like
twizzlers twizzler
everything everything so um so yeah
that's where i think i've become a
little bit more moderate over time
uh i still hate gluten yeah i don't eat
it um i think it was
like no no gluten in my house same eat
it yeah
i run a gluten-free ship over here in my
house
you know i only bring like grass-fed
beef into the house pastured eggs wild
salmon all that stuff
because if it's around it's as good as
in my stomach you know if it's in my if
it's even if it's in the shopping cart
it's in my stomach that's why i'm like
you know i'm
i'm always very careful about what i
bring into the house what i put in the
shopping cart
yeah i tell people that too if they're
trying to cut things out of their diet
they can't be in the house
like get rid of all the stuff give it
away yeah
for sure okay i asked my instagram
questions oh i thought it would be fun
to go through
a few questions with you i think you
answered some of them already in the
podcast one of them was is michaela
crazy for the lion diet
michaela's definitely not crazy thank
you max
you're not just saying that because
you're on my podcast right
i'm not just saying that no and we've
actually like we're not just internet
friends we've like hung out
in person so no you you bought me drinks
at the soho house that was so cool
yeah that was so fun that was fun
okay okay what is your you said you're
into fasting kind of intermittent
fasting have you done any extended
fasting or are you just into
intermittent fasting
yeah i've not done extended fasting i've
done i know that you've experimented
with this so you've done like three day
fasts
recently right i did an eight day fast
at a seven day fast
it was intense but you don't need to do
that i i did a dexa scan and my body fat
percentage was like
higher than it should be significantly
higher in a shocking manner
um so i figured i'd i'd do a couple of
fasts and see if it would lower but
now we're in a pandemic so i don't know
what i'm at now yeah i've never done
an extended fast but i do practice like
i guess intermittent fasting you know i
try to give myself a 16 hour
uh window every day where i'm not
consuming food and then
um i've done 24 hour fasts i've done
fasts where
you know if i'm traveling especially
you know extended distance i won't eat
plain food and i'll just eat
the next day um yeah super
convenient practical yeah i mean i would
say that the biggest barrier to
as to why i haven't done an extended
fast isn't a
lack of curiosity in trying it i've
definitely
you know i'm curious about doing it it's
mostly just the fact that i'm
around family and friends like
enough where i feel like it would be
difficult from a social
standpoint and uh and i just haven't yet
bitten the bullet to make that sacrifice
um yeah
that makes sense i think i i got through
all that like once you go to the diet
i'm on where all you eat is beef
the social aspect is already so weird
that not eating is
really not that different so funny i
kind of like
i skipped over that jump okay how do you
feel
oh well this is maybe a helpful one to
people who still eat vegetables out
there
potato chips are terrible for us but
they are delicious and addictive what's
the tastiest alternative
oh tasty alternative to potato chips
well i'm going to take a controversial
stance here
there i've seen some potato the problem
with potato chips is that they're hyper
palatable and it's hard to moderate your
consumption of them and you know it's
very easy to go through a whole bag
but if you're active and you can find
like
potato chips made in avocado oil you
know which is a
chemically stable largely
monounsaturated fat
potatoes are not the it's not like
they're you know they're a good source
of potassium
the problem is they're hyperpalatable
they're very calorie dense so i wouldn't
recommend buying them
i would say a much more a snack food
that's way
lower on the calorie density spectrum
and so it's really good for just like
volume snacking is popcorn which is
surprisingly
calorie sparse you know you can you're
into corn
sometimes like you know i have nothing
no problem with eating corn on the cob
like a whole corn
i think the problem with corn is that it
doesn't fall under grains for you
well it is a grain but like even white
rice i'll eat white rice on my sushi
if i'm being you know if i'm active and
you know it's like not i don't think
that it's
when you have when you work to build
more muscle
and i'm not saying that i'm like you
know like the most
muscled of the people in our in our
community but like you know i work out
pretty vigorously and like
i think if you if you do that you can
tolerate some
some starch you know like because you
have a place to store that starch you
know
muscle one of the one of the best things
about having more muscle in your body is
that they're the they're powerful
i mean they're they're aside from your
liver they're your body's soul glucose
disposal organs
um so having some white rice or even
some corn in that
in in that context if you're active and
you're exercising regularly
and you're on an otherwise low carb diet
you know it's not just like eating corn
on the cob
on top of 300 grams of carbohydrates
that you're eating throughout the day
that's not what i'm advocating but if
you're eating like a generally low carb
diet that's going to
allow for intermittent ketosis and then
you have a corn on the cob
you know on on top of that i don't think
that there's any problem with that
and so it makes sense for a snack food i
mean i think like
you know having some popcorn here and
there not it's it's high volume so you
can literally eat three cups of it or
whatever and it's like a hundred
calories
and then they have they're like some
coconut flour based chips that i think
are really good the danger with all of
them though
is that they're hard they're easy to
overeat and they don't provide much in
the way of nutrition
and you know my fear is that you're
going to get people that are
you know glucose and tolerant overweight
you know interpreting this as a green
light to go eat you know a bag of
popcorn every night that's not what i'm
saying you know
yeah i'm anti-popcorn yeah
i mean it's not a health food it's like
a snack food
um i ate i ate when i was like low carb
before the carnivore diet uh sweet
potato chips
that had you know a good type of oil i
had coconut oil sweet potato chips
and those are so much less tasty than
real potato chips that you actually
don't eat that many that's what i found
anyway
but not compared to like miss vicki's
regular potato chips
that's fair i could my problem is and
this is
this is why i feel like i relate to
the plight of your average person i'm
it's very hard for me to moderate my
consumption of those kinds of foods once
i start
like i can [ __ ] sorry i don't know if
i can curse on here but i can i can
murder a bag of like sweet potato chips
made in coconut oil
like i'll just murder them like this is
like gone in
20 minutes you know my brother my
brother has a joke he says i'm like
whole bagging
oh is max gonna be is max hole bagging
tonight it's it's true it's really
difficult to like
to to s to pump the brakes once you've
broken that seal
you know and so that's why all people
because i have difficulty like well with
hyperpalatable foods and
i'm i have quite a bit of self-control i
think
um and i have difficulty with stopping
as well
or i did when i was you know eating more
plants
but is that just normal for people what
do you think
yeah i think so i think that these foods
are just they push your brain to a bliss
point beyond which like self-control
yeah
is nearly impossible and not everybody
is like me
but i find that i can completely abstain
from these foods
but once i give myself permission to try
them
i go you know i tend to go overboard not
all the time
but but you know sweet potato chips
fried in coconut oil they're
delicious and you're programmed from the
standpoint of evolution
to want to consume as much of these
kinds of foods as possible it's not
it's not a lack of willpower it's not a
moral failure that's what i like to tell
people it's like people tend to go
through
you know when people end up going
through the entire pint of ice cream
when they only when they only intended
on having a
spoonful or the entire bag of chips when
they only wanted a few
and then they feel bad about themselves
that's not you shouldn't feel bad for
yours
for yours you shouldn't feel bad about
yourself this isn't like a moral failure
you're literally doing what you're
programmed to do which is
yeah you see uh you know an easily
accessible and abundant source of fat
salt and carbohydrates your brain is
just like it's thanksgiving you know
because from an evolutionary standpoint
like you didn't know where your next
meal was gonna come and these are
these you know fat is something that's
really important you know we need fat
fat is an essential macronutrient um
carbohydrates provide
you know an easy means of storing fat
sodium
you know sodium has now been demonized
just like
saturated fat cholesterol and all these
other you know things but sodium is
actually a nutrient we need sodium it's
a macro mineral we need like a large
amount of it every day in fact for good
health
uh and so when we consume these foods in
combination
which by the way nowhere in nature would
you find
carbs and fat and salt concentrated
they you know it's literally like the
fourth of july
fireworks going off in your reward
centers in your brain
so it's not a moral failure you're doing
what you're programmed to do knowing
that
having that insight and that information
i think
it allows for people to make decisions
based on informed consent and that's
what it's all about for me it's not
about like
demonizing any of these yeah that's fair
people should know right yeah if they
knew then they could make their own
decisions yeah
exactly i find abstaining i find
abstaining a lot easier than having a
little bit too
i did when i first went low carb as well
it's like i cut that and i have to cut
it out strictly um
when i first went gluten free it was
with gluten i'd have if i accidentally
had even little bits of it that
i didn't even really taste so this was
interesting i think it was microbiome
related maybe i'd get cravings again
even if it was like trace amounts of
gluten and suddenly i'd be thinking
about angel food cake for the next week
i'd be like i didn't even eat very much
of it that was interesting
okay what do you think here's perhaps a
controversial one
what do you think about the fat
acceptance body positivity movement
oh man uh yeah i'm not a fan of the like
the healthy at any size
movement i think that you should feel
positive about your body and not shamed
about your body
i was having this conversation actually
with uh our mutual friend dave rubin
i'm a huge fan of dave rubins and i
think it's important to
be able to this is something that he he
promotes and i wholeheartedly
agree you've got to be able to talk
about like the empirical facts about
health
and ideas about health separate from
talking about the people you know and
like individuals
and their various health issues so i
think it's important to say that you
know it's not
it's it's important to say that it's not
healthy to be overweight but by saying
that we're not
shaming people who are overweight yeah
unfortunately people today have such
thin skin that they will take you know a
statement like that and they will say
you know well max is shaming me i'm not
doing that you know i'm trying to help
yeah and yeah it's ridiculous really
i've i've usually told people who
you know are carrying extra weight and
are upset about it like
you probably got to where they probably
got to where they are
because they didn't know any better like
when i gained i went to university and i
gained like 30 pounds
quickly like a year and a bit and i went
from
like pretty underweight to like 30
pounds heavier than i should be
it was like what is happening because i
thought it was all
calories and exercise so i was gaining
weight thinking well i'm not
exercising enough i'm not pushing myself
hard enough and a lot of people who are
carrying extra weight
i think part of the reason there is um a
fat
acceptance movement is because a lot of
these people haven't tried
you know going low carb they've just
been exercising
for you know running i had one friend
who was running 10 miles a day and was
still overweight
and so they were like well this is my
body like screw off
everybody but if those some of those
people knew like maybe you're having an
issue with glucose
and it's not your fault but here's what
you can do about it that's a lot
different than being like no where
you're at is okay because even those
people i don't think they think it's
okay
yeah i mean i think that's like that's
the whole thing about
the calories in calories out crowd is
that
the the the what i perceive as being
like the
the take-home message of their plight is
that eat whatever
you could eat whatever junk you want
just eat lent less of it
and what that doesn't tell people is how
those kinds of
is how the foods that are that are
that are regularly available to them
affect their behavior and so that's why
i'm totally on board with the low carb
carb movement because i think that
that's going to be the easiest thing for
people to adopt you know it's like and
ultimately yeah if it doesn't work for
you it doesn't work for you
if you have if you just have to have
your morning bagel
uh there are ways to work around that
right but like
i think people owe it to themselves and
their health to be a little bit more
mentally flexible and to say well maybe
that morning bagel is like not the best
choice you know it's nutrient it's from
the standpoint of nutrition it's garbage
you know and it's also messing with your
hunger exactly
yeah we don't really know what it's
doing in the microbiome or
in regards to gut damage and yeah i
think one of the messages that we share
is a lot of these health symptoms they
start decades before you are actually
sick so like my autoimmune disorder was
severe enough that i
had symptoms and pretty much damaged
right away but most people
you know maybe they get sick when
they're 35 or 40
and so if they started eating healthy
when they were 20
even if it was like a limited amount of
healthy like
maybe go grain free and eat less
processed foods maybe if
that's all they did they could stave off
some of these diseases
a little bit longer or maybe completely
but people who are healthy
especially younger people don't care
and they really should because once
you're like walloped with
health problems or one of your family
members is walloped it
can destroy completely destroy your life
so like
pay attention sooner 1000
yeah there's a quote by jfk who you know
like
i feel like it's weird to hear a young
person quote jfk
because you know i certainly wasn't
around when he was alive but
uh you know it's one of these quotes
that just has stood
the test of time and i think it's so
applicable to health
the time to fix the roof is when the sun
is shining um
yes you posted that i reposted that the
other day i really liked that
yeah it's true that's what's up
yeah okay well i think we should finish
off this podcast by
another question this is an important
one as what's your favorite color
my favorite color that's actually a
pretty easy one
my favorite color is charcoal it's like
not
that's not a color what do you mean no
that's just not a color you can't choose
like black
well it's not black it's not gray it's
sort of like in between
um i guess other than aside from that
now you can keep charcoal i don't care i
like charcoal i like
if you actually if you look at my closet
even though there's a hoodie that i'm
wearing right now
it's charcoal yeah i don't know why i
like it so much
my mom always thought that i was a uh
she always like
she would she loved to shop with me for
clothing but she always like
also hated shopping with me because i
was such a pain in the butt
because my taste is just so from a
clothing standpoint so narrow but
charcoal if you go through my closet
it's like all charcoal yeah
that's fair that's fair well thanks max
thanks for coming on
you're the best michaela i can't wait to
hang in person when this is all over
and um yeah thanks for doing what you do
okay thanks i'll talk to you soon
[Music]
you